bonsoir emballages werder faire merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
votre client qui a donc renoncé à cette
désobéissance civile finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il en a dissuadé jeu rift
et du coup d'abord et les annonces ce
matin effectivement de bruno le maire
annonce est extrêmement claire annonce
qui consiste en une menace toute assez
univoque c'est à dire que s'ils ont
bravé l'interdît et bien écoutez les
sanctions étaient financières étaient
manifestement immédiate de chefs que rio
ait déjà une situation financière
extrêmement compliqué c'était très
difficile d'en rajouter
et effectivement lorsque nous nous
sommes retrouvés sur place on a trouvé
un accord pour mettre en place un
protocole pour servir les plats du
restaurant mais dans des conditions
respectueuses du protocole sanitaire
actuelle donc ça veut dire que cet appel
à la désobéissance civile de certains
restaurants aujourd'hui d'une certaine
manière c'est tombé à l'eau
parce que bruno le maire a menacé de ne
plus payer ces êtres c'est bien ça mais
vous savez les restaurants se sont
arrêtés ça va bientôt cesser et plus de
trois mois les restaurateurs beaucoup de
restaurateurs ont de grosses difficultés
financières si vous voulez donc
effectivement si en plus de ces
difficultés financières et ils ont
besoin de rouvrir travailler pour
regagner de l'argent pour payer ce
qu'ils doivent payer et c'est vrai que
les aides aujourd'hui ne permet déjà de
ne permettent pas de faire ça si vous
voulez à tous les impératifs
si en plus on se rajoutent des sanctions
pécuniaires très significative partir de
ce moment là pour le chef du rayon c'est
c'est le dépôt de bilan c'est le dépôt
de bilan avec les licenciements qui vont
avec ce n'est pas non plus ce qui est
souhaitable
ce qui est souhaitable et ce qu'on
cherchait avant tout parce que cherchait
le chef du rayon dans son action c'est
surtout de créer un dialogue constructif
pour évoluer par rapport aux règles
sanitaires actuelles concernant les
restaurants
alors c'est important de le dire a
souligné cet objectif à ce qu'il a eu
gain de cause finalement ce chef et des
autres restaurateurs évidemment à
travers lui parce que y at il vraiment
un dialogue
puisque bruno le maire a répondu par le
chantage on peut appeler ça comme on
veut mais voilà vous ne respectez pas la
loi je vous coupe les certaine manière
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de
dialogues n'ont ils pas d'éloges pour
l'instant ce sont les menaces étaient
c'est choquant d'ailleurs que un
ministre s'exprime de cette façon là on
descend directement des gens qui ne sont
pas des voyous qui sont des travailleurs
qui veulent juste se travaille et qui
ont des impératifs financiers importants
et c'est bien qu'ayant c'est très mal
vécu ce qu'ils te connaissent
derrière tous ces chefs des familles il
ya des engagements financiers on ne peut
pas faire n'importe quoi si vous voulez
la désobéissance civile à laquelle on a
appelé ses pour entrer dans une phase de
discussion avec l'exécutif mais surtout
parce qu'on aimerait d'abord que nos
politiques locaux et malheureusement on
peut déplorer qu'on ait pas eu de
députés présents pour représenter et
porter la parole notamment de ses
restaurateurs à paris on souhaiterait
vraiment que les décisions sur les
ouvertures de restaurants soit chaire
est plutôt par les municipalités au cas
par cas en fonction de chaque restaurant
et ce serait beaucoup plus réaliste
beaucoup plus respectueux aussi des uns
et les autres et des destins intérêt que
sur l'intérêt finances économique où
l'intérêt de sanitaires par des gens qui
sont sur le terrain qu'ils connaissent
le restaurant vous prenez le cas du chef
thuriau la vente à emporter et à 70
personnes qui y habitent à cuzance ou
des faits recommande la vente à emporter
ne peut pas travailler
donc il est primé totalement son chiffre
d'affaires s'est pas du tout adapté et
c'est pas le seul car bien évidemment je
me suis amusé à chercher la définition
de la désobéissance civile en préparant
cette interview en a plusieurs mais
l'une d'entre elles c'est le refus
assumé une public de se soumettre à une
loi et un règlement une organisation ou
un pouvoir jugé inique par ceux qui le
contestent tout en faisant de ce refus
une arme de combat fait spécifique
la notion date de 1970 même d'avant mais
il a été repris par un philosophe
alors la question vous pose mettre les
principes égalité liberté ne sont ils
pas respecté aujourd'hui par ces
restrictions sanitaires
et notamment par les restaurateurs qui
en sont victimes l'égalité liberté
égalité souvenirs égalitarisme
aujourd'hui on est dans l'égalitarisme
c'est à dire tout le monde est sur le
même plan vous avez des entreprises des
restaurateurs qui avec les aides
accordées arrive à faire face et puis
vous en avez d'autres c'est le cas par
exemple du chef du rayon qui on est dans
les mondes investissements très lourds
investissements
beaucoup de salariés et qu'il n'arrive
pas à faire face donc l'égalité n'est
pas la même pour tous à partir de ce
moment où il ya des situations
profondément différente entre les
restaurateurs
donc on peut pas considérer
qu'aujourd'hui on serait dans la
légalité on est plutôt dans
l'égalitarisme et l'égalitarisme en
général ne prend jamais en considération
les situations particulières qui sont
très nombreuses faut bien vous y avait
une chose c'est que les chefs qui
veulent rouvrir aujourd'hui c'est pas un
caprice si vous voulez c'est un
impératif financier avec le chef du
rayon on a regardé les chiffres sont
clairs si on continue comme ça l'est
mais ça peut être le dépôt de bilan
ça peut être le dépôt de bilan c'est
vrai qu'à des restaurants qui ouvre de
manière clandestine
un article du parisien qui indiquait
d'ailleurs des magistrats des politiques
des journalistes fréquenté ce type de
restaurant on comprend que c'est pas la
même démarche vous l'avez bien expliquer
puisque le chef turrian notamment
voulait ouvrir le dialogue vers il le
faisait en indiquant qu'il allait le
faire
mais question tout de même ce sera la
dernière l'avocat que vous êtes peut-il
cautionner d'une certaine manière le
fait d'enfreindre la loi puisque
finalement c'est tout de même de ce pack
il s'agit au final mais vous l'avez dit
si vous voulez dans une démocratie et et
j'ai peur que la notion de démocratie ce
père profondément pendant cette période
où les choses ne paraissent assez
liberticide si vous voulez le droit à la
désobéissance civile c'est un droit
constitutionnel
c'est un droit qui existe si vous voulez
on est une république démocratique et on
est une république démocratique et s'est
construit sur ce droit là comment
refuser aux citoyens un moment de
l'irlande comment refuser aux citoyens
de vouloir le dialogue avec ceux qui
sont censés les représenter
ce qui est choquant dans une démocratie
c'est que ce qui représente le peuple
qui travaille dans l'intérêt du peuple
ne l'écoutent pas voir le méprise est
aujourd'hui le menace et ça c'est très
choquant pour l'avocat je suis très
attaché à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme
très attaché à la constitution et à
l'application des principes de cette
constitution y compris le droit à
l'insurrection civile pacifique
merci beaucoup en tout cas randall
schwerdorffer d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france